I expected a hard fight you know I put
my family through a lot
more you get hit the harder you fight I
get it let's go only now you taking way
too many hits where you get off you
can't find like that anymore think about
her I'm tell you some you owe me I love
you so predictive awesome man the light
heavyweight champion I wouldn't be here
without my wife Marie I really why you
leaving so soon i keep watch baby you
ain't never been real real man Thank up
let's go home well I take your belt whoo
but not no no no no no no no
this court is aware of the tragedy your
family has suffered mr. hope
nonetheless you have chosen to
demonstrate dangerous behaviors while
having custody of your daughter that you
need help really it'll be a year before
your suspension is up which means zero
income legal custody of the child shall
remain with family services until the
father can demonstrate the abilities of
a responsible parent
come with you no I got do this alone so
what brings Billy Hope DiMaggio I'm
looking for a job maybe place a trade
you couldn't handle the rules here but I
can't lose my daughter i'll give you my
everything I know that you're mad at me
right now you don't know anything she
doesn't want to see you today tell her I
love her got a letter H so she can get
better I'd you'll have to fight at that
time you think that you could beat
mention not without you I again when i
get my kid back what chance is there
that Pope could win because the stick
guess hope you're doing okay make this
your time is your mom you can control
your day